is it wrong to try to pick up girls in
the dungeon sort of auditoria episode
one we kick things off back at the
beginning of season one but we are
following ice and the Loki family this
time on an expedition into the dungeon
the episode follows leafy abetted ease
and elf with confidence issues she gets
scared and messes up her in conditions
while fighting so she feels like she's
letting everybody down they are on for
50 when they get ambushed by powerful
caterpillars imagine dying - a powerful
caterpillar what a shitty story to tell
in heaven or hell even though they
managed to fight them up we have you had
froze during the fighting and was pretty
much useless
so they take too much damage and end up
having to turn back while heading back
they proc another attack from a group of
minotaurs ice chases after one of the
minotaurs as if flees which is when she
runs into Bell in Episode one of the
first season episode if everyone returns
home and Loki croak sleepy oh like she
normally does to make her feel better we
see that ice is starting to get restless
on her stats not changing as fast as she
wants maybe Oh looks up to ice and
doesn't want to see her being all
depressed so she tries a variety of ways
to cheer her okay silicon to jump ahead
to where Beth day was making fun of Bell
in the bar causing him to run away from
embarrassment
the next day we get some more filler
content of the girls going shopping II
episode 3 we Pia had made plans to go to
Monster philia with ice but gets cut by
Loki who wants ice to go as her escort
this is when freya sets monsters free
and ice helps defeat the monsters before
anyone can get hurt hey Pia and the
others run into one of the monsters and
lethea ends up getting injured in the
fight ice has to bail them out once
again but Lee Pia doesn't want to keep
being useless and getting saved by ice
she finally is able to work up the
courage to cast a powerful spell
defeating the monsters they were
fighting later we learned that Brea
wasn't actually the one who set those
particular monsters free yep so for most
of the Loki family head back into the
dungeon because ice needs some money to
pay her blacksmith well on their journey
they learned that there was actually a
murder on the 19th floor meanwhile back
in town loki thinks something is off so
she goes with Beth day into the sewers
to find out what happened at Monster
philia well down there they run into
more of the plant monsters that attacked
we Pia and the others at the festival
birthday manages to kill them and both
of them return to the surface on their
way back they run into Dia nieces and
bet they recognizes his set from the
sewers raising
suspicions he explains that he was
searching for answers on the monsters as
well and isn't responsible for the
attacks back on over to the murder ice
chases down lulu-nee Louie who had the
victims possessions and it's likely the
murderer is now after her to get what
she has the culprit then launches his
attack with more plant monsters
ambushing the village episode by who
okey family are all forced to fight off
the attacking monsters after some
fighting the culprit in the murder is
found out to be the hot ginger Revis who
attacks ice and leaf via to get the
victims Luke the loot turns out to be a
little creature inside of a crystal that
comes to life
and empowers one of the plants ghoul
okey family make quick work of the plant
and then rushed to help ice who is
losing her fight against Treves Finn is
level six and proves to be too strong
for the assailant to handle so she is
forced to retreat we later learned that
during the fighting the attacker had
called ice aria
which was the name of her mother
suggesting some sort of connection
between the two ice wasn't happy that
she was losing to the assailant so while
heading back she wants to stay behind in
the dungeon to get stronger
Quinn agrees to this on the condition
that Riviere accompanies her in the last
scene we see the two of them preparing
to fight the floor boss by themselves
episode six ice fights alone requesting
that Riviera not step in and quickly
defeats the boss while heading back we
see another scene from season one when
Belle had just learned magic and mind
zeroed in the dungeon he wakes up gets
flustered and runs away
so I sniper gets a chance to apologize
for bethe day making fun of him at the
bar ice rinks up to level six which is a
big deal but she doesn't seem that hyped
up about it because she's more concerned
with apologizing to Belle jump ahead a
little bit in season 1 to where Belle is
getting scanned so I nerd requests Isis
helped to protect him in the dungeon she
protects him from the dungeon monsters
right before he rushes up to catch up to
Lily who had taken his dagger once he's
gone Isis approached by a mysterious
hooded mage Feltz who's associated with
the guild saying that she has a quest
for her II episode 7 there is some sort
of monster attack on floor 24 that could
be associated with Revis so Isis
requested to go there to help mookie
finds out about this and sent some of
her members to help ice in case she gets
in trouble tmesis also asks fill this
who is one of his followers to
along with them and help out ice runs
into lulu-nee and her family who are
looking for the monsters also so they
decide to party up and go look together
they find the monster soon after and the
ginger Revis ends up isolating ice from
the others episode 8 ice fights with the
ginger while the others run into one of
her masked accomplices who stabs ass
feet they learn from the accomplice that
the gingers overall plan is to destroy
the city of audio he takes off his mask
revealing that he's Olivos who was
supposed to be dead but was somehow
brought back to life Ravi's ends up
killing him and eats the stone keeping
him alive to get more power everything
starts to collapse around them and
Rabbie's tells ice to go to 459 and once
there she'll find what she's looking for
episode 9 ice finally gets to return
bells equipment as well as apologized
like in season 1 she wants to train him
because he's improving at such an insane
rate so she wants to figure out how he's
doing it media finds out about this and
gets jealous of Belle so she requests
one-on-one training from ice as well in
season 1 on the day ice takes off to go
with Belle to get new equipment levia
had gone to train in the dungeon with
phil this boobas had taken a liking to
leafy hawala
on their expedition because everybody
was saying that Phil this was cursed and
if you go into the dungeon with her
you're gonna die but Lydia doesn't care
about that so that you become friends we
see that Isis trying to get stronger
because when she was younger something
happened to her parents but we don't
learn too much about them well heading
back from training one day Belle and ice
can ambush in the last scene episode 10
the attack is brief and just a warning
from the assailants to stay in the
dungeon and out of their lady's way ice
has a hunch that they were members of
Freya's family before the Loki family's
expedition into the dungeon where they
plan to reach 459 lulu-nee gives ice
some rations before they leave she also
gives her a blue crystal that she got
from Belle's to give to ice along with
the advice to wear it once they get to
459 drew up ahead to win Belle and Lily
get into a fight with the Minotaur that
o-tar had been training on for his
orders so that it could eventually
attack Belle while rushing to his aid
Isis stopped by o-tar who challenges her
to a duel to stall her from getting to
him with the help of the others they
slip past him just in time to watch
Belle fly and defeat
minotaur episode 11 back on over to
floor 50 where the others are preparing
to make their push into floor 51 with
new weapons and equipment the next day
the group makes their move and starts
fighting their way through the floor
once they get to floor 52 dragons shoot
flames through the ground creating
massive holes Media falls into one of
the holes
so Beth ATO Nate Tiana and Gareth jump
in after her and planned a free fall to
floor 58 meanwhile the others will take
the main route and meet up with them
there everyone regroups and secures
floor 58 which is previously where they
had to turn back they proceed on into
uncharted territory on 459 where they
find that it's a jungle floor once there
they find a spirit plant that's going to
be their first challenge on the new
floor episode well the group engages the
spirit but their attacks don't do any
damage and it launches continuous
powerful spells after the initial spells
are done they have to take a second to
regroup but then launch their
counter-attack everyone is getting
messed up and ice is almost taken out by
a spell but lethea managed to protect
her ice then goes in to deal the final
blow defeating the spirit with the help
of everybody else after the credits we
jump over to Fell's who is talking with
the god of the guild or right ups he
explains that the spirit they ran into
there was likely an offshoot of a god
it's true form lies in a deeper floor
and has been alive for more than a
thousand years the corrupted spirit is
what's causing the new species to start
popping up in the dungeon like the evil
caterpillars but I guess that's not the
only thing to worry about
as they speculate that it's working for
n yo the one who will wipe audio out I'm
gonna be doing the next season and if
you find that on the left side whenever
I'm finished with that or you can check
out all of the is it wrong to try to
pick up girls in the dungeon recaps in
the playlist on the right side you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing I hate more
than intros is out robes